It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
I am not Mococo, I'm Raora!
BAU BAU!
Today, we're your hosts on FUWAMOCO Morning!
We're all here to thank you!
Ruffians, thank you for joining us on FUWAMOCO!
I'm excited for this episode today!
Surprise!
I'm so happy!
Big morning!
Thank you for joining us today!
Thank you for having me!
Dog house!
I'm in the dog house!
Now it's my house!
Big cat house!
Big dog house!
Now, this is the dog house.
Dog house!
This is dog house.
Cat house.
For now.
I understand that maybe this could be a little bit confusing.
No!
For those who are joining us for the first time, hello!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday!
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
How do you feel about it?
Is this the first time you've been on such an early morning stream?
First FUWAMOCO Morning together.
I feel like maybe sometimes we're earlier than usual.
Maybe sometimes.
Maybe not that often.
Wow!
A new week is starting!
Yeah!
Happy Monday!
We started on the right paw!
Take a look at some interesting and fun things that have happened!
Yeah!
Let's see.
Moco-chan.
FUWAMOCO!
We have a guest here!
What happened?
Why are you sad?
There's been a perrocite.
Today is just a perrocite.
What happened?
Moco-chan, what was Pero sporting?
Let's take a look, okay?
Let's find out.
De-den!
Cute!
It's cute, but in the center there's something kind of nasty there too.
It looks decorative, but it's not cute.
I don't know at all at all.
There's some really cute ones here, but, well, what should we do?
Give me like a nasty one!
No, no!
Why?
Does he deserve to have a decorated photo clip?
And no, is he some sort of celebrity?
No!
I like Pero.
You what?
How?
How say that again?
What?
I like.
I like Perroccino.
You like nasty things?
Eh?
No, Pero is not nasty.
It's cute.
Look at him.
Surround.
Wait, wait.
Raora, can you say The Great Perroccino in Italian for me?
Perroccino?
The Great Perroccino!
The Great?
Yeah!
Uh... Il...
El Magnifico Perroccino!
You shouldn't be saying that, you know.
You don't know what kind of power that has.
Okay, I think that means, you know, we have these really cute photocards.
But Pero needs to be ripped in two again.
No, no, no.
I'm perfect.
I'm Pero.
I'm perfect too.
Rip the nasty one in two, okay?
Or you could give it to Lala, maybe.
No.
FUWAMOCO Morning has officially started!
Good morning!
We started the day on the right paw, right, Ruffians?
Don't let Pero get in your way or not.
On the topic of chaos, the other day we had a bunch of chaos in Among Us!
It was a very special collab organized by Kiara-chan and I because we wanted to play Among Us.
So a bunch of people from the gallery all got together and we played Among Us!
No I'm not!
I wanted to be an imposter so bad!
I didn't realize!
I feel like you were though!
I was really scared of you.
I thought you were the imposter.
You know what guys?
I am justice.
I cannot be the imposter.
That is why.
She lies so easily.
What do you mean?
No, I don't lie!
Don't!
She's saying she's an engineer!
I am an engineer.
I don't know what to believe.
She's an engineer.
I can bet.
I'm an engineer.
Look at my degree.
The degree?
I have a degree.
I have a degree in science!
Show me, Fuwawa!
If you're an engineer, then what color is red?
I think it's red.
What does an engineer have to say to back up that?
Okay, I know what- I know, I know.
I'm an engineer.
Somehow this all has to do with the chaos that erupted in Among Us.
It was so much fun!
FUWAMOCO, should we talk about the part where you killed me?
We killed you?
Yeah, you killed me.
I don't even remember that.
It was such a small memory.
It was so insignificant.
Should we talk about that?
I just wanted to kill.
It was so insignificant, I couldn't remember.
I don't know who's foot was on our paws.
It did not even cross my thoughts.
Oh, that's why.
Someone help me.
They trapped me in the dark house.
We had a lot of fun!
And if you want your tummy to hurt, go check it out.
There's a lot of different perspectives.
You can hear a lot of different FUWAMOCO screams.
Probably.
On different streams.
Yeah.
I hope we can play more together.
Yeah!
I'm a monster!
You're a monster, right?
You're a monster.
And Calli-senpai.
Next time.
Maybe.
Two pink members.
Go Impostors!
BAU BAU!
You watch it?
You watch BOTTOBOY POV 3?
Yeah!
Thank you!
Are you still hearing all the screams?
Afterwards, the emergency button press is always like... Now she becomes the emergency button.
Yeah, she's the emergency button.
Just pop the hat, you know?
BAU BAU BAU BAU
Is that your momo sounds?
That's my momo sounds!
We definitely have to play again soon!
Please check it out on K-Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And also, FUWAMOCO news!
Over the weekend at FUWAMOCO, we had our very first arrival festival in Japan!
BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
I don't know how, but FUWAMOCO is the first member in EN to have an arrival festival!
It was so much fun being able to explore Hollow Earth all together with the Ruffians!
We need to do it with the Chachini too!
What is Hollow Earth for those watching this?
What is holo-earth?
Well, to explain, holo-earth is a project to recover for the next evolution and bring hololive talents together with you in a way not possible before in a new immersive social experience.
I see, that explains a lot, huh?
We can have a lot of fun that we can't have usually through holo-earth.
You know we had to watch along and watch the environment too.
We had some tracking.
We had to move around.
Pretty funny.
We also got a little creative.
Not as creative as Dora.
But we designed our very own t-shirt too!
It's cute, isn't it?
It's the latest BAU BAU t-shirt!
So cute!
What do you think, Ruffians?
It's adorable!
I love it!
It's very nice.
Maybe it's hard to notice, but the pink and the blue part is actually a bit transparent.
Like watercolors!
Cute!
But I got the bubble!
Thank you!
But, but, but!
You can get it in hololive and also in real life too!
So if you wanna wear it maybe while you're going to the gym.
Or maybe store.
You know, or just running out to get some groceries.
Or pajamas.
Yeah, it comes in a bunch of different sizes.
It's on Amazon.
There's a lot of different sizes and hopefully it should be easier to make.
And you're gonna ride railways.
Railway, right!
I wonder, Raora, what would you do if you could do a t-shirt like that?
Maybe I would ride no jetpack for today.
No jetpacks?
Maybe I'll write big cat means big t-shirt.
I like that one!
That's so cute!
Big cat means big t-shirt!
Because I love oversized t-shirts, right?
So I think it fits!
I was thinking for the no jetpacks one though.
It can say no jetpacks on the front, but then on the back...
FUWAMOCO No!
No jetpacks!
Not for you Moco-chan.
It's for your own safety.
Don't cry now.
I can't have a jetpack?
No, you cannot have a jetpack.
Can I have a scooter?
A scooter?
You can have a scooter in holo-earth!
Well, we'll think about it and we need to see if we have budget for this, Moco-chan.
I have an inventory, it has a scooter, but it doesn't do jumps and it doesn't do tricks.
I need it to do that.
When you get hurt, then it's my responsibility.
Why?
Then, I was wrong.
Moco-chan happened to die in Hollow Earth, which was kind of embarrassing.
So, I fell!
Okay!
I fell with a big splat.
Yeah, we were playing a bunch of parkour classes at the rock climbing.
Yeah, that day means!
And that's when Moco-chan fell.
But maybe then, you'll have your own arrival festival.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
FUWAMOCO
I second one ever!
But now it's nine!
You're pretty good at eating so far, right?
I'm not that good.
I tried this a few times.
Do you have any tips?
It's not rocking, right?
I don't know about that.
I think I just like to, you know, use things that are, you know, I just like to listen to and I try to replicate.
So maybe try to find the things you like to listen to.
What's your secret weapon against the Chichinus?
I don't know.
I like when I burn to the mic.
Yeah, like softly.
Like a birthday cake?
Chichinus!
I like it.
I see, we haven't tried something like that, huh?
Also, I had my maid outfit when I had my ASMR thing.
Cute!
Maid aura!
We'll have to try a lot more stuff, too.
But if you want to check it out, it's in the Doggy Pack, okay?
Let's give you a tip, too.
FUWAMOCO!
PROMISE!
They released a new cover song all of them together of UMAPUI LEGEND on IRyS-senpai's channel!
Oh, and you're embarrassed now.
No, why, why?
We're jealous of you, Moco-chan.
I thought I was the only one who was interested.
The thing is though, UMAPUI LEGEND as the title would imply, it's UMAPUI DANCES in ENGLISH!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
Amazing!
BAU BAU!
We have a certain guest here with us today.
What does this mean?
Rawa does bath from the moment it's born!
Finally bath!
My mom made so much food for me.
I got to spend some time with my sisters.
I got to rest a little bit.
It was really nice.
I could hug my grandma again.
Bubi?
My cat!
Did you get to hug?
Kiss?
Sniff?
Hug?
Everything!
I love my cat.
He looks like a cube.
A what?
Cube.
I thought you said he looks like a cube.
I would say more like a sphere.
A sphere.
He looks like a sphere.
More accurate statement.
Have you ever seen a cat like a cube?
Yeah.
He's like a ball of four.
You know, you're a cat.
What shape do you think you are?
I am a big cat.
Is that a sheep?
Big cat sheep.
I am not a sheep.
For some reason when you say big cat sheep, I think of a gummy bear.
Moco-chan's gonna eat you!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
To eat mine.
You know what's gonna happen.
Moco-chan?
Moco-chan!
Come back.
No!
We agreed that no one would touch each other's tail right before coming here, right?
Moco-chan!
No!
Okay, come back.
Moco-chan.
We still have more to talk about here.
You're dubbing that face here.
Hi.
You're making the sounds that Nerissa does when she kisses Moco-chan.
But your tail is so fluffy.
No touching.
Your tail is so fluffy.
It's at least fluffy.
It's so fuzzy.
What's the next topic?
I was gonna say I'm glad you had a good trip in the Romance Empire.
I hope nothing unexpected and bad happens.
But I'm glad to have you back here too, Laura!
I'm happy to be back.
Moco-chan, there's a request that you have for Laola.
It's a souvenir from the Romance Empire.
It's not that special.
But I wanted Laola and I to say something because I thought the Ruffians would think it's cool.
This girl happens to look exactly like FUWAMOCO-chan.
Beatrice.
Again!
Beatrice!
Say it like that!
Not with pizza.
Pizzazz.
Okay, there's no pizza.
Beatrice and pizza?
Beatrice and pizza.
Is that a new pizza?
It's a different...
FUWAMOCO!
At Bingsuino, FUWAMOCO!
We got to watch a movie!
With Calli-senpai!
One that she really wanted to watch with us!
The Prestige!
It was a lot of fun!
But you know Calli-senpai really wanted to watch that with FUWAMOCO.
Nowadays there is a movie that you can make us watch and watch together with us.
Together?
That's hard to say.
I don't know.
I'm more into TV shows.
What TV show?
I'm watching... I forgot the name.
I forgot.
Maybe the Ruffians know what it is!
Describe it!
Okay, so it's a show where when you go to work, you split into, you know... You forget about your life, and then you just sever and sever.
Oh!
I've never heard of that!
You split into different life?
No, yeah, so basically when you go to work, you forget about your life.
Reproduction?
Huh?
I'm so confused, what is this?
So, yeah, so when you go to work, you go into this elevator, and in this elevator, you forget about your life, and your life is just about work.
And then, when you come back, you don't know about work, and it's just your life.
It's just, it's like living two different lives together.
It's like the on-off switch?
Yeah, it's kinda like that.
Yeah.
I watched that with you, Nalana.
Really?
It's very nice.
I just almost... I think I finished the second season.
Is it relaxing or stressful?
It's very stressful.
It's not stressful.
I just like stressful movies.
Why is it stressful?
I'm not good at watching stressful things.
It's really stressful.
If we could make Nalana watch a movie with us... Yes!
It would be Space Adventure Cobra, right Moco-chan?
Yeah!
Just like we made all of Elephant ones together in Space Adventure Cobra.
It was very cool.
It's a classic.
Oh Moco-chan, you have another one.
Princess Switch.
A classic holiday movie.
Really?
Who watched it?
It's famous.
Moco-chan likes it a lot.
Really?
I need to go watch it again.
Oh, but baby, we'll have to have some more movie parties all together then.
Yeah, this is hopefully in the future.
As well as marshmallows.
BAU BAU!
B
A green thumb when it comes to cooking.
A green thumb for cooking?
Yeah!
I recently started to eat more healthy.
So I wanted to, you know, discover all the nice recipes and, you know, try to be creative with food.
Because we need to eat vegetables everyday.
I love veggies!
Wait, wait, what's your favorite vegetable?
Mine's broccoli.
I like broccoli!
But do you like Brussels sprouts?
I was scared for a moment.
I thought you were going to say like onions or tomatoes.
I don't like onions.
I hate onions in fact.
Do you remember when they drugged me in my 3D debut?
That's right.
I was holding the cucumber.
The cucumber though!
I'm glad I didn't have to hold the onion, but the cucumber is yum.
I don't want to hold the onion, I'll take the cucumber, thank you!
What have you been cooking though?
So yeah, I'm doing meal prep, you know what that is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Meals all at the same time.
Wait, meal prep?
Meal prep.
So yeah, I am preparing like every Monday, Tuesday, I prepare like food for the entire week.
So even if I'm super busy with you know, streaming, recording, and everything else, I still have nice food to eat and ready.
What's your favorite one?
My favorite one is my super chicken burrito.
What's in it?
High protein, low calorie, and it's super filling.
Is it all refrigerated or frozen?
Yeah, you can froze it.
So I cut the chicken, right?
And I put some sauce, some spice, and like, you know, paprika and everything.
Is there any lemon in that?
Yeah, lemon too.
It sounds complicated though.
No, it takes like 20 minutes.
Wow, that's about the same amount of time as our meals.
Yeah, we've been having a lot of hot pots.
I put mentaiko in it.
Have you had mentaiko before?
I think so.
It's yummy.
It's like a spicy cod roe.
I put komatsuna in it.
I love it.
It's very...
Mococo.
Smoothie!
You just said Mococo's tail.
No, no, no, no!
Smoothie!
Moco-chan looks like you're gonna have to sleep with one eye open, huh?
BAU BAU!
BAUIDO!
That's such good news!
Ruffians, let's all do our best to maybe try to make some more healthy, vitamin-balanced choices!
Vitamins, nutrients, all the good stuff.
Make sure to eat your greenies every day!
Don't be like, oh I don't like veggies.
Eat the good ones.
You'll find them.
BAU BAU!
That makes me excited for dinner tonight now.
Ruffians, don't you want to have dinner?
You have breakfast though, right?
Breakfast?
Coffee!
Coffee is not breakfast!
Coffee is breakfast.
It's the best breakfast in the world.
Ruffians, you're with me, right?
Ruffians!
R
Oh man, good!
You know, maybe there's some Ruffians that haven't had breakfast yet.
What are we gonna do about that, huh?
Yeah, maybe you have something that's almost as good as breakfast that you could share.
I need energy.
Yes, I want something.
I have a cattle.
Hey, Ruffian!
Kanto time!
Some mornings feels like you've just spawned into the day with zero energy, still half asleep while life is already running, and it's totally normal!
Pause and give yourself a mini reset, slow breath, sip of water, a tiny stretch, maybe a song that you love, and even a silly gif if you want!
Little things worth, like, tiny powers up!
And still, even if it's still heavy, you can share a meme, you can reach out, you can text a friend, and you can ask for a hug, and you can watch FUWAMOCO Morning!
That's no weakness, okay?
It's moral healing!
Every step counts, you're doing better than you think, and we're here to cheer you on with
I'm a FUWAMACO!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAM
Have a howl of a day!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Wow, so elegant.
Well, now that I'm done, how do you think Furuya BAU BAU is?
Hmm, let me try.
BAU BAU.
I can hear it right from the painting.
Right?
Wow.
Very distinguished.
Do you think I know it?
I do, I do.
Moco-chan would be like BAU BAU!
Hey!
She's so cute.
So refined.
Apparently she also has as much energy as Moco-chan.
But she knows you know when to just take a deep breath.
Take it easy and just sunbathe right in a nice grassy field.
Now I have her beat.
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our corner.
Today, I went on a walk.
Ruffians, where are you going?
Let's take a look.
De-den!
I'm so glad you're able to get a nice photo.
I eat them.
I got the sound of eating snacks!
That's how I eat them.
I'm glad you're able to have such a nice time and thank you for watching before too!
BAU BAU!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Let's see!
De-den!
Hello FUWAMOCO!
With Hashtag HOLOCTOBER starting again soon, Iofi-senpai sent a drawing prompt advice.
With HOLOCTOBER starting again soon, I was wondering what prompt you would pick if you were in charge of choosing one.
I'm excited to see lots of more FUWAMOCO art soon!
Maybe there's some Ruffians that haven't played a whole October before.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Yep, 30.
31?
How about you, Fuwawa?
Maybe one going back in time to the Showa period or something, you know what?
Showa era!
Time to heal F, right?
Maybe like Dagashiya, like the old Japanese sweets shop?
Yeah, that'd be cute!
It'd be cool to have a red door!
We have Showa era, we could have Seiko-chan cuts.
Can you imagine that?
All of us are seiko-chan kai.
Seiko-shi's a baby.
Oh, I know.
Moco-chan, what about you?
What about you, Moco-chan?
Maybe... Wait, squeamish with a green bangle.
And I... Socks and then I... Band-aid on the knee.
Maybe red glasses.
That's all!
Wow, that's a long one, Moco-chan.
I think you said the same thing.
Because it's cute.
It's a good comedy.
Idol, police, those kind of things.
One prompt is different than the others.
That's all, chan.
We welcome all prompts.
I got it today, bro.
Thank you.
Pumpkin skirt.
Pumpkin skirt?
Pumpkin skirt is also very cute.
We can't wait to see how everybody gets up to that.
Thank you Iohei-senpai for always
FUWAMOCO Morning is something that we make together with you.
So that means
We're always looking for more doggy of the days!
By seeing your walks, photos of your walks that you've been going on, your adventures!
Send us your questions!
We know you have lots of questions.
And also you know if you happen to see a Pero Sighting, it's probably best to report it.
You can use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Don't forget!
BAU BAU!
The three of us, FUWAMOCO!
We have...
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't know.
There's a link on Twitter, you can ask us there!
And we'll do our best to answer them!
Oh I guess I should put it in the description.
Oh I guess, huh?
I guess that would've been helpful, FUWAMOCO-chan!
Ruffians, go to- Oh, you submitted yours too!
Thank you!
We'll be taking a final look at it soon, so please send us your questions, okay?
Make sure, okay?
Sooner than later is best, always.
Yeah, and we'll be doing it at 6 p.m.
PT tonight, so we hope to see you there!
Bye bye!
And for all the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU DAO!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us today, FUWAMOCO Morning!
I'm so happy to meet you!
I'm happy to join you so much!
I admire you guys so much and FUWAMOCO Morning is amazing!
I had big fun!
Thank you for having me!
Thank you for joining us!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Sonic Alpha!
BAU BAU!
Ashu!
Santa Williams.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
No!